Speaker 1: Let's talk to some more
people. It's Friday after all. We
take calls via discord David Pakman dot com
slash discord. Why don't we go next? Later,
we'll see where we go. But let's go next to
Joseph from Tucson, Arizona. The place in
Arizona where I've spent the most time by far.
Joseph, welcome to the program. What's going on?
Speaker 2: Thank you, David. Can you hear.
Speaker 1: Me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: So just hypothetically speaking,
yes, if Trump were to get indicted sometime
this year and Trump supporters
were to violently riot in response,
yes. Would that hurt Republicans in 2024?
Speaker 1: Interesting question. I think the
answer depends on who's the nominee. Right.
If Trump is indicted and his supporters riot
and Trump doesn't denounce it and he is the
nominee, I think that that hurts Trump. If
Trump gets indicted and his supporters riot and
Trump either drops out or loses the nomination,
I think that whoever is the eventual nominee
probably isn't affected negatively by these
hypothetical Trump riots you're talking about.
So I think it depends on who is the nominee.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Interesting. Yeah. I was kind of
thinking along similar lines where it definitely
would hurt Trump. Kind of in either way. Kind
of damned if he does, damned if he doesn't kind
of thing. And deservedly so, I'd probably say.
Speaker 1: What do you mean by that? Damned if
you're saying whether or not he
denounces or. What do you mean?
Speaker 2: I think either way, he
definitely would face a lot of backlash,
obviously, from the left. But I think
in a lot of pockets of the right,
it's a combination of a Trump indictment
and violent riots were to occur. I think a
lot of the smaller pockets of the right who are
more quiet about their disdain for Trump would
be a lot louder, I think would get a lot more
support because of such a violent occurrence.
Speaker 1: That very well may be. That
very well may be. Let's hope there is
no such violence. That would be the best thing.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that would obviously be the best
the best course of action. And as
a kind of unrelated side question,
sure. I was wondering if you had any book
recommendations related to U.S. foreign policy.
Speaker 1: I really don't. I tend not to read
sort of like a new foreign policy type books.
I have so many other things on my on my pile,
including science and narrative nonfiction and
history and different things. I just don't I'm
not really reading in that genre right now,
so I don't have any recommendations.
Speaker 2: Okay, That's fine. All right.
Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right,
Joseph from Tucson, great to hear from you.